you know in the morning gary plays me a
lot of tape of uh different things that
i'm going to use on the show
and then if i take a second to like if i
pause he starts singing to himself
and annoys me more than him clearing his
throat but i've been ignoring it it's
been going on for a few weeks
wait a minute you got to explain this to
me you're talking to him and then all of
a sudden i go hey wait a minute cause i
need to
organize it or think how i'm going to
present it to the audience
and all of a sudden you're here
[Music]
and he starts to sing a song like it's
one of his songs he can't even let you
think
no and he can't stand waiting
yeah do you want a duty it's so quiet i
don't even know that other guys hear it
really so he's singing real low also my
dude
it's like it's like he can't be quiet
for a second
he wants to keep verbalizing oh
here she comes yeah like yeah it's like
it's like daryl do you know you do that
no wow it's wild no i really don't yeah
i didn't think you did
i wonder if hein realizes it where's
john hine wow
i'm like that's fascinating but you know
everything i notice
because that's just me i know that's
everything you're not you're sitting
there trying to think and he starts
singing
yeah but it's very sweet you're not even
there what the [ __ ] do you know go with
some faults she gets it no
it's really crazy
[Music]
johnny are you aware of it do you ever
hear it i hear gary talk to himself
sometimes
yeah like mumble to himself because he
can't stand to be quiet but i haven't
heard him sing
now that should have been in his book
the list of songs i sing
listen to songs in my list of songs i
sing when howard is ignoring me for two
seconds
and as soon as you're ready to go he
stops the singing and starts his next uh
thing
yeah it's just it lasts for five seconds
but it so blows my mind
because it reminds me of a little kid
well it's another numbing another thing
i'm unaware of that i will apologize
for you he doesn't even know he's doing
well when i'm trying not to clear my
throat i'll try not to sing i have a
listen i have so many lists of things
not to do i don't know what to do
i think it's tied in with you clearing
it i think maybe you want to keep your
voice clear
that could be yeah so he starts lickless
there's no pleasing you no i mean it's
it's a subtle thing you don't even know
i really want to yeah i really don't
know what i'm doing
follow my ball [ __ ] believe hold on
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey just go hey gary you're singing i'll
go oh okay and i'll stop
yeah but i don't want to that would be
much more than this i don't want to
control
but you're controlling me now i know and
and you're controlling me in front of
the whole world
right which is much more humiliating but
this is a great
story yeah it's kind of great yes it is
it's fascinating what you do
my wolf is the best my boss is thinking
[Music]
well it's monday morning so as always
i'm sorry
you